♪♪
-We're going to get to the news.
While touring the demilitarized
zone on Thursday,
Vice President Kamala Harris
mistakenly said
the U.S. has, quote,
"an alliance
with the Republic
of North Korea."
It's a huge blunder that many
are calling presidential.
[ Laughter ]
Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas's wife Ginni
testified on Thursday before the
house committee investigating
the Capitol attack in
a four-hour closed-door session,
and no matter how much
the committee begged her,
she would not open the door.
[ Laughter ]
The National Archives said last
week they still did not have
custody of all missing records
from former President Trump's
administration.
And this is absolutely
the first time Donald Trump
has ever fought someone
for custody.
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] It's all yours.
[Normally] According
to newly-released documents,
the FBI spent years
surveilling the late singer
Aretha Franklin, which isn't
surprising if you've seen
and of her performances
from the '60s.
[ Laughter ]
So I guess that's an FBI agent.
Ordering from a giant menu.
[ Laughter ]
The FBI used to dress like
"Inspector Gadget."
[ Laughter ]
When he was preparing to leave
Walter Reed Medical Center
in 2020 after being treated
for the coronavirus,
then-President Trump reportedly
told aides he wanted to exit
the hospital in a wheelchair
and then stand up to reveal
a Superman shirt, you know, just
like Superman would never do.
[ Laughter ]
A little league baseball card of
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg
sold an auction last week,
and even then, they knew he
wasn't going to be an athlete.
[ Laughter ]
The New York sandwich shop
Katz's Delicatessen in Alidoro
announced the release of a
New York subway-themed sandwich.
The way it works is you eat
the sandwich while a stranger
masturbates next to you.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
That's right.
Katz's will release
the so-called 1904 Signature Sub
this month
in honor of the subway system's
118th birthday.
And if you're wondering what
the subway was like
118 years ago,
ride it.
[ Laughter ]
Disney World fully reopened
to its normal hours
over the weekend
after Hurricane Ian,
and it's pretty much the same,
except now, the whole place
smells like wet Goofy.
[ Audience groans, laughs ]
Oh, you're all on board for
the subway masturbator.
We draw the line at wet Goofy.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Chipotle is set
next month to begin testing
its new kitchen robot
named Chippy.
And to give you the authentic
Chipotle experience,
the robot will be high as hell.
[ Laughter ]
[Robot voice]
"What did you say again?"
[ Laughter ]
Ha ha ha ha.
While in Puerto Rico yesterday
touring hurricane damage,
President Biden said
that his home state of Delaware
has a large Puerto Rican
population
and added that he was
"sort of raised
in the Puerto Rican community
at home politically."
Whoa, just take it easy, dude.
You sound like someone's grandpa
the first time
they meet a gay person.
"Hey, nice to meet ya.
You know, we had a gay fellow
in Vietnam with us.
At least, you know,
we all thought he was gay
on account of -- yeah,
doesn't matter, you know.
Nice to meet ya.
Do you fella shake hands or...?"
"Grandpa, stop talking!"
[ Laughter ]
It was reported that
Pennsylvania Senate candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz's research team
at Columbia University
killed hundreds of animals
over several decades,
including 329 dogs.
Even crazier, it was reported
in his campaign ad.
[ Laughter ]
Producers of
the Netflix series "The Crown"
have announced a casting call
for an actor between
the ages of 16 and 20
to play young Prince Harry,
and an actor between the ages of
55 and 60 to play young William.
[ Laughter ]
A former girlfriend of
Republican Senate --
Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
claimed in a new interview
that Walker paid for her
to get an abortion in 2009.
And the only way that will
hurt him with Republicans
is if some of that money went
to pay down her student loans.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
I don't know. I'm going to stand
by that one.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
visited a Waffle House
restaurant over the weekend
and served food to linemen
working to restore power
in the aftermath
of Hurricane Ian.
"Thanks for everything you do,"
said DeSantis
to his photographer.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump filed a
defamation lawsuit yesterday
against CNN and claimed
that the network has made
a "persistent association
between Trump and Adolf Hitler."
Yeah. Come on, CNN.
Can't a guy
hold a series of racist rallies
in a country
suffering skyrocketing inflation
without being
compared to Hitler?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Peloton. Peloton news.
Peloton announced
a new partnership with Hilton
yesterday
to put exercise bikes
in more than 5,400 hotels
across the country.
Not to be outdone,
Days Inn announced towels.
[ Laughter ]
In a recent interview,
country singer Shania Twain
said that
she wants to collaborate with
Harry Styles in the future.
"Hey, so do we,"
said the rest of One Direction.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced that
the world's largest
indoor go-kart track
will open in New Jersey
later this year,
will include four passing lanes.
But since it's in Jersey,
there will always be
a kid in the left lane
going 15 miles per hour.
[ Laughter ]
We have one writer
who lives in Secaucus.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna do what we always
do -- take his word for it.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, rapper Snoop Dogg
announced yesterday
he will release
a cannabis-infused
onion ring snack
called Snazzle Os.
So, if you like marijuana
and you like onion rings,
you don't say.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden toured hurricane
damage today in Florida
and met with
Governor Ron DeSantis.
And Desantis has been
working around the clock
to recover from wearing
this outfit.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden tweeted
a picture of himself this week
in a green sports car.
Oh my God, look at him.
[ Laughter ]
He loves his wife,
yet has the energy of a man
who was divorced an hour ago.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Biden ] "Got me a hot young
girlfriend, too. She's 65."
[ Light Laughter ]
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is reportedly planning
to order a nuclear test
near the border of Ukraine
to demonstrate his willingness
to use nuclear weapons.
Oh, you don't have to
prove you're crazy.
You ride horses half naked
and your best friend
is Donald Trump.
We see you.
[ Light laughter ]
According to a new report,
staffers who worked in former
President Trump's White House
were not surprised that in the
raid of his Mar-A-Lago residence
the FBI found
highly-classified materials
mixed in with news clippings
because trump never followed
the strict rules
for handling
sensitive documents.
Also, you're not gonna
believe this,
he never separated his trash
from his recycling.
[ Laughter ]
And in a new animated
"Scooby-Doo" Halloween special,
the character Velma Dinkley
will be depicted as LGBTQ.
Now, you might be thinking,
"What about Fred?"
But hear me out.
[ Laughter ]
Hear me out.
Fred is an overconfident
white guy
who thinks he's a detective
just because he owns a van.
He's definitely straight.
[ Laughter ]
He probably has
an alt-right podcast
where he complains
about Velma being gay.
[ Light laughter ]
New York Yankees star
Aaron Judge last night
hit his 62nd home run
of the season
breaking --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, give it up for Aaron Judge
breaking Roger Maris'
American League record,
And to add insult to injury,
the ball hit a Mets fan
and killed him.
[ Laughter ]
And you know what the Mets' fans
last words were?
"At least I don't gotta watch us
blow it in the playoffs."
[ Laughter ]
Al Pacino is reportedly closing
a deal with a publisher
to write a book.
It will be the first
autobiography
written in all caps.
[ Laughter ]
Very, very unfair photo.
[ Light laughter ]
But that is his writing face.
According to new reports, prices
for real Christmas trees
are expected to increase
this year,
so expect some changes to
Rockefeller Plaza this December.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to
a new survey,
60% of Americans said they have
never cheated on a partner
in a relationship,
and if you have to ask,
"Does it count if --"
the answer is yes.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today
traveled to New York.
Said New Yorkers,
"Oh, my God! Move!"
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis said
that the media's coverage
of Hurricane Ian was motivated
by a political agenda, adding,
"I mean, as soon as it was over
there was a rainbow
outside my window."
[ Laughter ]
[Mockingly]
"That's not political? Okay."
Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's campaign
has announced that since he
was accused earlier this week
of paying for
his ex-girlfriend's abortion,
it has raised
more than $500,000.
In fact, it's going so well,
Walker's thinking about asking
all his exes to come forward.
[ Laughter ]
FEMA announced yesterday that
phone operators from the IRS
have been brought in
to help the agency
handle the volume of calls
after Hurricane Ian.
So now getting help will be just
as easy as doing your taxes.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is Russian President
Vladimir Putin's 70th birthday,
where he will blow out
the candles
and then push the cake
off a balcony.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
said in a speech yesterday
that he is being targeted
by the FBI because,
"They want to silence me."
Hey, it's not their fault the
only way to truly silence Trump
is to sit him down
for a deposition.
[ Laughter ]
A new list
from "Fortune" magazine
has ranked CVS Health
President and CEO Karen Lynch
as the most powerful woman
in business --
because she's the only one
with the key to the razors.
[ Laughter ]
That's -- That's power.
A 17-foot-tall statue
was recently unveiled in Canada
of a giant hand holding a Cheeto
with orange dust
on the fingertips.
So the other statue
obviously looked like this.
[ Laughter ]
Two right hands.
It's a statue
with two right hands.
[ Laughter ]
The world's oldest living dog,
Pebbles, died recently
at 22 years old and 50 days.
"You son of a bitch!"
[ Laughter ]
It's a bummer I went
into that joke
laughing about
the weed fingertip statue.
I'm like -- "Ha ha ha ha!
The world's oldest dog died."
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
spoke last night
at an event
at Arizona State University,
and because it was ASU,
she made sure to speak slowly.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, we have an issue here,
I want to admit.
Our head writer, Alex Baze,
went to University of Arizona,
and so he oftentimes
will write jokes
that are very unkind
to Arizona State University.
So I'd like to apologize to
anyone who went to that school,
who's currently going to that
school, and let's move on.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
spoke last night
at an event
at Arizona State University,
though I'm not sure why
they needed a congresswoman
to read off the beer-pong rules!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
I mean, University of Arizona
is not Harvard, dude.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so, we asked another
writer to cover this story,
because obviously Baze
cannot get above himself here
to do this.
And finally Mike Scollins --
Our good friend Mike Scollins
chipped in here.
And finally
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
spoke last night at an event
at Arizona State University.
Well, at least everyone there
is used to not getting
their first choice.
You guys!
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a monologue, everybody!
♪♪